[Musik]
heute bin ich mit den jungs von der
frankfurter entsorgungs und service gmbh
unterwegs und schaue mir an was mit
unserem plastikmüll passiert nachdem wir
den weg geworfen haben
ich treffe mich mit dem müll fahrer
markus luca und seiner mannschaft
mein erstes mal müll verladen uns
aufregend aber eigentlich gar nicht so
kompliziert
danach brechen wir zu einer tour durch
frankfurt bonames auf und natürlich
möchte ich auch mehr über den job der
männer in orange erfahren
[Musik]
hier fand täglich mit 99 lkw sind jetzt
aktuell die einzelnen nur plastik nur
plastik also dsd duales system
deutschland das ist der begriff für die
plastiktonne und die wird täglich in
frankfurt von circa neun lkw gefahren
jeder lkw hat zehn bezirke insgesamt
wird die gelbe tonne in 90 bezirken
gesammelt ich frage marco appel
gravierende unterschiede zwischen den
bezirken gibt außerhalb frankfurts dann
geht's mit der trennung wenn wir dann zb
neuem hauptbahnhof viertel also statt
mittel da ist es mit der trennung dann
schon etwas anders genau stehen lassen
oder uns die zeit nehmen zu
kontrollieren ob die in ordnung sind ob
wir die laden können
wir fahren im 14-täglichen rhythmus und
da merkt man schon zwei wochen
stillstand bei den tonnen dann sind sie
schon ziemlich voll
ja definitiv wenn wir die tonnen laden
dann kriegt man öfters mal mit wo dieser
plastikmüll herkommen da sieht man schon
vermehrt dass das es fiel auch durch
dieses online geschäft ist nicht nur
aber auch anderer mythos hinter gibt es
das gar nicht lohnt zu trennen weil am
ende
wird es wie so alles zusammengeschüttet
bestimmt kein aktiver stimmt nicht
ansonsten würden wir die arbeit umsonst
machen gelb laden und schwarz laden und
braun laden was wir hier laden wird
möglich dann auch getrennt verarbeitet
weniger verpackungsmüll verbrauchen
beziehungsweise zweimal überlegen bevor
man sich jetzt was kaufen tut ob das
jetzt wirklich mit verpackung sein soll
oder ob man wirklich darauf verzichten
wir leben in einer wegwerfgesellschaft
dann überlegt man zwei mal und dann geht
sofort an die gelbe tonne und dann hat
man noch mehr probleme
[Musik]
am ende der tour fahren wir zur ackerl
umlage anlage hier wird alles was wir
auf unserer tour gesammelt haben auf
lkws geladen und in sortieranlagen
geschafft
[Musik]
den müll in solchen bergen zu sehen ist
schon echt beeindruckend
er stinkt nicht so schlimm wie ich
gedacht hätte aber trotzdem frage ich
mich wie man den ganzen tag hier
arbeiten kann
wer einmal beim müll war kommt immer
wieder zu müll zurück ich habe ganz
viele andere sachen gemacht und bin
jetzt auch nach langer zeit wieder
zurückgekommen weil sie sieht einfach so
an würde ich sagen
ich sehe hier vor allem viel müll aber
was wird hier eigentlich genau gemacht
also die spedition kann den abfall jetzt
in sofia anlagen und wer wird der abfall
dann in verschiedene fraktionen getreten
so weist mit folien tetrapacks flaschen
aluminiumdosen das wird ja alles an
rausgezogen und geht dann eine separaten
verwendung erfolgt erzählt mir dass die
deutschen ihre mülltrennung echt noch
verbessern könnten
sind menschen die mit müll arbeiten
eigentlich auch die besseren und renner
ich glaube ich bin ein ganz normaler
bürger wie jeder andere auch also wir
trennen den müll natürlich aber dass ich
das jetzt besonders beachtet würde ich
jetzt wirklich mal was halten sie denn
eigentlich von der aktuellen plastik
debatte ja man hätte früher schon
aufschreiben müssen ja jetzt ist es
schwierig glaube ich noch viel zu ändern
man kann nur beraten die bürger und
immer wieder darauf hinweisen aber was
man jetzt im endeffekt dagegen tun kann
ein schwieriges setzen wir schon
vielleicht schon vor 10 15 jahren
anfangen er hat es leider noch keine
hilfen
[Musik]